cartuchos armas de fuego y explosivos
son tan solo algunos de los objetos que
recuperó la policía militar en la
penitenciaría nacional de hombres en
Tamara a 45 kilómetros al norte de la
capital de Honduras es el comienzo de
una operación que tiene el objetivo
explícito de pacificar las cárceles del
país la orden emitida por la señora
presidenta hemos iniciado el proceso de
transición de los centros penales
de la Policía Nacional hacia la Policía
Militar hemos iniciado con la requisas
para poder tomar el control de los
centros y la medida se deriva de la
determinación tomada por la presidenta
Xiomara Castro La semana pasada la
mandataria izquierdista ordenó a la
policía militar tomar el control de las
cárceles luego de que murieran más de 40
mujeres en una prisión
un suceso que ocurrió tras el
enfrentamiento entre reclusas de La
Pandilla barrio 18 y de la Mara
Salvatrucha el pueblo Hondureño puede
ver que las cárceles han funcionado como
escuelas del crimen tienen un Arsenal
adentro los resultados no serán esperar
en favor de la seguridad las imágenes de
Honduras recuerdan a las del país vecino
El Salvador donde su presidente nayib
bukele ha implementado una controvertida
guerra contra las pandillas una que ha
calado en cierta parte de la población
hondureña aquí en Honduras se impone la
misma energía que tiene bukele allá en
El Salvador aquí viviríamos más
tranquilos las cárceles en Honduras
están en un estado crítico no solo por
la violencia el país tiene 26 prisiones
superpobladas según el informe de la ONU
están 34,2% por encima de su capacidad